So now let's look at what happens when we need to dispatch instructions. So
this is the situation in a cycle. Dispatch basically means to
consider latching operations results that are produced, and
also deciding which instructions are ready to execute. So in the same cycle,
usually we'll have both of them. So we will consider the situation where we
can actually, kind of at the beginning of the cycle, do this and
then towards the end of the cycle, actually choose among the instructions that
are ready to go. None of these instructions are ready to go.
So if we did it the other way around in the cycle nothing would really dispatch.
So now let's do it. What's going to happen is, when we broadcast the result,
we say which Reservation Station is producing the result. And what the value is.
And now what happens is this. The reservation station who's result is
being broadcast know that this reservation station has already dispatched this,
it was executed, it was broadcast et cetera so night comes back here.
We're now going to free this reservation station base its finished its job.
So the first thing we're going to do is free this reservation station.
Now it's empty and is ready to receive another instruction that issues.
The next thing that we're going to do is match this tag against each of the two
operands in each of the reservation stations. So what's going to happen is RS4
doesn't match, so we're not going to do anything for this. RS1 here does match,
so instead of RS1 here we are going to use a value of minus 0.29.
For this instruction, it already has a value here,
so we don't have to match anything. But RS1 here does match so
we're going to take the value of 0.29. And here we have another match. Oh,
zero oh, this is minus zero, okay, minus 0.29, and this value's already here.
So this completes, basically, what happens when a result is kind of being
broadcast as far as reservation stations are concerned. Now we need to consider
which reservation stations have all the operands ready to go. This one doesn't.
This one does. And this one does. Because these are going to different execution
units, assuming that in each execution unit can take one operation per cycle.
This instruction RS4 is going to execute in the multiplier. So
the multiplier for a while it will be busy with the, you know RS4.
This is a divide. And it's going to be basically doing this over this.
And then here. This one is not ready to go so the only one that
can really go here is this one so what we will be doing for awhile is RS3 minus
0.29 plus 2.72. Once these are done,
they're going to broadcast their results and this cycle will repeat